here for reaction author of beyond biden
former speaker of the house and fox news
contributor newt gingrich mr speaker
thank you so much for being here um what
is their goal uh you they can't look
around and say that begging opec
and tapping the strategic oil reserve
and all this inflation and what they're
seeing at the pump they can't know
that's a political winner so they must
be searching for something else or
believing in something else
well i think you're dealing with a
semi-religious belief system
big government socialism has its own
internal logic
you know they don't think very far ahead
in a world where you need to be able to
play
four-dimensional chess to be a leader at
that level they can barely play
tic-tac-toe
uh and as a result i mean you saw with
granham you you have a secretary of
energy who when asked about 10 days ago
what's her plan broke up laughing
sounding like kamala harris yes when
asked a very basic question how much
oil does the u.s consume in a day
she had no idea i mean it's clear that
in a administration that was competent
she'd be gone but since this
administration is incompetent in
virtually every area she's just one more
example of the team the team's
incompetent at the border it was
incompetent trying to get out of
afghanistan it's incompetent with
inflation
uh why would you expect her to be any
more competent than the rest of the team
and you know i mean hillary represents
sort of the
sour grapes of the past but also the
classic democratic view
she has no idea how the world really
works and she has no idea how to be
honest about these things because if she
was honest she'd have to say you know
when biden's at 38 and kamala harris is
at 28
and i i saw one study today there are
only six states in the whole country
where biden has a net positive six
states
in the entire country uh and and i i
think the fact is
that
big government socialism doesn't work
now
they can't say that because it's a
belief system sure you're dealing
basically with a a it's a secular
religion
and so they they simply shrug all the
evidence off
and they think it can't be true uh so
this guy who clearly was a criminal
clearly should have been locked up
clearly it was deliberately killing
people
their media which is a propaganda media
of the left that's not a news media
their propaganda media can't even report
that he killed people and so it becomes
sort of this strange accident that
happened uh if you read the news the
initial reports it's bizarre
but by the way that's what the new york
times did with stalin in the 1930s it's
what they did with castro in the early
1960s this tradition of lying about the
left is nothing new
and has a very deep lineage
in places like the new york times it's
just spread over the last 50 years what
used to only be a handful of newspapers
is now virtually the entire journalistic
enterprise
and so the average american doesn't even
know
exactly what's going on frankly unless
they watch fox yeah or listen to talk
radio but they're not going to get it
out of the traditional news media and
they tell us they care so much more than
us their intentions are what matter and
at the same time you're right in the
media it's gone from bias to agenda and
now all out sheer activism the book is
beyond biden mr speaker thank you so
much for your insight one shot one kill
there